as the supreme court weighs a case that
could strip away federal abortion
protections under roe v wade some states
are preparing for a surge of
out-of-state patients illinois will be
the only one standing in the middle of
the country to absorb thousands tens of
thousands of patients who will now be
sort of mass mobilized to be able to get
that care a leak of a draft opinion
indicated the supreme court may overturn
roe v wade meaning abortion laws would
fall under states control one state
could go as far as banning most
abortions
in that state and another could continue
to protect abortion rights as it stands
currently
health care providers are expecting an
influx of patients traveling to what
some people are calling abortion islands
these are states like colorado and
illinois where abortion access is
protected but are surrounded by states
with more restrictive laws
since the implementation of texas's sbh
we have seen a substantial increase
almost 150 percent increase in the
patients we are seeing outside of our
service area it's going to have a huge
strain on what is an already fragile
abortion access network so how are
abortion providers in states like
illinois preparing for the possibility
of a post-row america and what does it
mean for the surge of patients seeking
care at these facilities
as many as 26 states are expected to ban
or restrict access to abortion if the
supreme court overturns roe v wade
lawmakers abortion providers and
anti-abortion groups have been preparing
for this shift for years
so trigger laws are these pieces of
legislation that about 13 states have
passed in recent years and they're
designed to fairly quickly and in some
cases immediately ban abortion if the
supreme court overturns roe v wade
meanwhile some other states have
pre-roe v wade bans on abortion that
could potentially take effect as well
illinois is among several states that
are becoming a refuge for abortion
access it shares a border with missouri
one of the 13 states with trigger laws
just as missouri has been passing
legislation to restrict access illinois
has been doing the work on the other
side to ensure that access to abortion
is secure not just for its own residents
but for those who are going to be
fleeing from their own states dr colleen
mcnicholas is the chief medical officer
for the st louis planned parenthood
branch which operates medical clinics in
both missouri and illinois the clinics
provide a range of reproductive health
care services including abortion care in
2019 planned parenthood built a clinic
in fairview heights illinois to meet the
growing needs of out-of-state patients
it's located about 15 miles from the
missouri border we were strategic about
both where we were going to build this
facility how big we were going to build
this facility it is right along major
highways so thinking about how people
are going to need to travel
it's not far from an airport so for
folks who are going to need to fly they
would be able to do that
illinois borders five states that could
ban or further restrict abortion if
federal protections are overturned
missouri and kentucky have trigger laws
in place
iowa currently bans abortion after 20
weeks of pregnancy and could pass more
restrictions if roe was struck down
according to the guttmacher institute a
policy group that supports abortion
rights and tracks national abortion
statistics wisconsin has an unenforced
abortion ban that predates roe but it
could go into effect if the decision is
overturned and indiana may also take
steps to outlaw the procedure according
to the guttmacher institute
this will be a public health crisis that
this country has not faced before where
because states will be abdicating their
responsibility to basic health care
normal healthcare life-saving healthcare
we are now going to have to figure out
how to mass mobilize
up to 36 million people who are capable
of getting pregnant to a very limited
number of states in this country after
texas passed legislation last year
banning abortion after about six weeks
nearby states like colorado reported a
rush of patients that has meant that the
number of abortions performed in texas
has fallen by about half according to
the state but also that means that a lot
of people are traveling out of state for
abortions in illinois the uptick in
patients from out of state is already
happening according to the state's
health department
in 2014 nearly 3 000 non-residents
received abortions compared to more than
9 600 in 2020
and we are requesting 151
from the chicago abortion fund that
sounds correct
this is the regional logistics center at
the planned parenthood in fairview
heights illinois here call center
employees connect patients with
resources to cover transportation and
medical costs tied to abortion services
all right so that leaves us with the
balance of 151 dollars
if you live 300 miles away from this
last and only remaining abortion clinic
we're talking about navigating hundreds
of miles more than one time on a very
tight time frame where you have to
negotiate time off of work and child
care and reliable transportation for
many people it just puts abortion out of
access and so in january we stood up
what we call our regional logistics
center which manages those navigation
tactics and logistics for all of the
patients coming to southern illinois
if roe is overturned planned parenthood
says the southern illinois region could
see upwards of 14 000 more patients each
year while many patients are from
bordering states others come from as far
away as texas sometimes traveling more
than 900 miles as more patients flood a
smaller number
of providers we are going to see wait
times go up we are already hearing from
folks that the first two or three
clinics that they contacted have three
and four and five week weights it means
if you want medication abortion you
might be pushed out of that particular
service line or for some people you
might be pushed out of abortion care
altogether to get ahead of the expected
surge the fairview heights planned
parenthood is adding new positions it's
also considering operating seven days a
week up from six with 12-hour days and
nighttime shifts and so we are hiring
lots more folks not just in our clinic
worker space but also hiring a lot more
case managers those folks who are
working in the regional logistics center
another way illinois providers are
preparing to meet the surging demand is
by allowing nurse practitioners and
other advanced practice clinicians to
carry out abortion procedures along with
the fairview heights facility planned
parenthood built two new abortion
clinics and health centers in flossmoor
and waukegan near the indiana and
wisconsin borders anti-abortion groups
meanwhile are working to build more
crisis pregnancy resource centers in the
chicago area i've spoken with some
anti-abortion lawmakers or
groups in other states that fear that
the accessibility of abortion in a state
that borders their own
kind of threatens the impact of what
near a ban on abortion or near total ban
on abortion might mean
illinois right to life is an
anti-abortion organization focused on
educational outreach in a statement a
spokesperson for the organization said
we will continue working to make sure
that women across illinois know that
help is available that will benefit them
as well as their children both born and
unborn
the supreme court's decision on roe v
wade is expected by the end of june or
early july as the country awaits a final
decision abortion providers are
mobilizing to expand access to patients
the biggest challenge is going to be in
getting folks to that care in a timely
manner the other real important aspect
of
a post-role reality is
making sure that folks who are
terminating their pregnancy are free
from criminalization
[Music]
you